what i should have did when i signed
with the major i should have took my
advance instead of going to do my [ __ ]
and shaw you know i love cars and [ __ ]
instead of doing that i should have
spent all that money
on
the music and [ __ ] myself and just got
the money back from him later yeah
because you had to use that budget and
then you had budget you got to pay that
back right on top of the events and so i
should have just took the advance and
jump started myself but
see this the thing between indies and
majors well empire i don't know all
indies but like empire and then i had a
situation with priority this the thing
like when you sign with a major they
give you your advance but
you got to have some [ __ ] going or you
got to have the entire office convinced
for your budget to even open up you know
what i'm saying so you got to jump
through loops and do a gang of [ __ ] to
even get going in the first place even
after you sign after you did all the
work and sign for them to approve video
budgets and all of this [ __ ] gotta make
sense it's so much [ __ ] so much [ __ ]
red tape that you got to cut through now
with empire
whatever you [ __ ] sign whatever your
budget is is right there
you could go get straight to it
immediately you ain't got to waste no
time now if you [ __ ] it off that's
honestly that's on you now if you do
your thing
then i mean naturally if you're a
businessman you're going to do your
thing so i mean that's the that's the
great part about empire like they just
let you go